hello everybody and welcome to the
continuation of the matplotlib series in
this video in the next few subsequent
videos we're going to be talking about
3d plotting so pretty exciting stuff so
with that let's go ahead and hop in and
get right to it so first thing that
we're going to need that you'll notice
is a little bit different is from NPO
underscore toolkits dot and plot 3d we
want to import axes 3d so basically so
we can start to use that axes 3d
framework the next thing we need is
import mat plot live pie plot as p LT so
that's not new so next thing we want to
do is we want to define our figure so
this is also nothing new it's just going
to be fig equals plot figure the next
thing we want to do is define the axes
so we're going to say ax equals fig bad
underscore subplot and so far that's not
new and same thing with subplot those
same rules apply this is 1 1 1 now what
will be new is you're going to have this
new parameter called projection and
projection is our way of telling mat
plot lib that we want to have this be a
three dimensional projection so as it's
creating the axes in this subplot it's
doing so with a three dimensional object
in mind so now the next thing that we
want to do is we want to specify the
plots that we want to make so in this
case we work we're going to need three
right we've got an X a Y and a Z and X Y
Z is going to be equal to the plots for
three different arrays so that's going
to be array 1 2 3 so this will be the X
plots the Y plots and the Z plots and
they have to obviously equal the same
right you need 10 X is 10 Y is 10 Z's
and so on so we're going to use just one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten for the X you can make up whatever
plots you want by the way I'm just going
to make some random ones real quick so
you should do the same thing you won't
have to copy me or anything for one two
and then this one would be two and ten
so I think one two three four five six
yeah I think we've got ten now we'll
find out probably an easy way to do it
would just be to well never mind anyway
so define your X Y Z well no if it
doesn't plot if we did it wrong so now
we do a x dot plot and so that's not
anything new but now you do plot
underscore wireframe that's what we're
plotting is this wireframe and then in
here you put what you want to plot and
our case we want to plot XYZ and then
finally end with a plot show and that is
really it so let's generate it hope it
on any typos let's see what do we do
yeah okay we did we'd somewhere we've
got two incompatible dimensions we would
probably this one since we're counting
the other ones one two three four five
six seven eight nine so we'll just add
ten okay save and we'll display this now
it's getting angry it's angry at me at
least mine does gets really angry at me
whenever I fail at displaying the chart
so anyways here is our chart as you
might find out immediately you can begin
playing with the chart by left clicking
and dragging that will rotate the chart
around and you can mess with it however
you cannot use the home button you can't
so if we do this and you hit home it's
not really doing anything for us you
also can't use back and forward to
previous views because it's constantly
being rendered basically I don't think
it's recalling where it is like this is
still the same thing that it's showing
us anyway
you won't be able to use those you could
use this thing
doesn't do anything actually the same
thing zum-zum doesn't do anything either
so you might be asking well how do you
zoom them because what if you really do
want to zoom well to zoom you'll
actually use your right mouse button so
just right click and hold and you can
zoom in and out and then you know you
can zoom out and then continue playing
with it a little bit looking around and
that kind of stuff
and the other thing that will work as
well if you'll notice we not only have
these spaces here on the chart the chart
itself not on this side so much because
the numbers are there and I the reason
that spacing is there is because the
numbers can flip-flop right you can have
numbers on either side but it's a waste
on whatever side there are no numbers so
say you wanted to you know render this
into an image or something then you
might want to adjust with these this
little adjuster thing you know that your
should be used used to by now and at
least get rid of you know like the top
and the right maybe and then we'll go
ahead and get rid of left and then even
the bottom in this rendering we could
get rid of so now you know it would be
like a full sized image and really this
one you know such from these going over
that's why they made the spacing there
mostly is because I guess it'll go over
but anyway that's that that's it those
are these charts or at least the
beginning of the 3d charts there's all
kinds of charts that we can do you can
do bar charts either like flat bar
charts or thick bar charts you can make
it look like a city in here basically
scatter plots which is useful for
machine learning for sure especially
with the third dimension and and some
other stuffs especially like the planes
people really like to see like planes
like probably this most stereotypical 3d
plot that you can think of so anyway
with that that's going to conclude this
basic tutorial we will be continuing on
with some more of the 3d plotting
tutorials that's for sure
I just wanted to put this one out before
people started to mutiny over my
wordpress tutorials and I wasn't putting
anything else fancy out so anyway that's
the first 3d plot and as always thank
you for watching thanks for your support
your subscription
and until next time